[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: Food trucks used
to only sell sandwiches
and other prepackaged food.
Not anymore.
The modern food truck
is a mobile restaurant
with a full kitchen inside.
Food is cooked fresh
and sold to customers
through a service window.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Most food trucks are
standard panel trucks.
Their cargo area
is a fully equipped
commercial kitchen with a
service window on one side.
They're usually customized
by boutique companies,
so there's no standard method.
However, certain modifications
to the panel trucks
are common, like enhancing
the truck's suspension system
or reinforcing the flooring
and walls to support
the kitchen's weight.
To lighten the
load, this company
builds the kitchen's structural
components out of aluminum bars
rather than heavy steel.
Once the pieces are
cut, a worker assembles,
then welds them together.
This structure will support
a stainless-steel countertop.
Workers cut the countertops
and cabinets from thick sheets
of stainless steel.
They bend the sheets using a
machine called a press break.
For this countertop, they
bend a 90-degree angle
on the front end to form
a 1.5 inch square edge.
To construct walls
and ceilings, they
rivet thin sheets of
stainless steel or aluminum
to panels of wood.
Fire-retardant plywood
is used for the kitchens.
The boards are installed
over Styrofoam insulation.
They leave the truck's
aluminum floor as is.
Once the walls, ceiling,
and flooring are complete,
it's time to install
the kitchen's
cabinets and counters.
Workers screw each
counter support
to the wooden
structure of the wall,
then fasten the
countertop with rivets.
They peel off the film
that was protecting
the stainless-steel surface.
Next, they install
the major appliances,
which include a
commercial refrigerator,
freezer, and cooking equipment.
Then the electrical
box is installed.
They connect wiring
for the outlets,
lighting, water
heater, water pump,
and air conditioning system.
The generator is installed
underneath the nearest counter.
It supplies the truck
with electricity.
Next to the electrical box
is the power transfer box.
It contains a switch
that enables the truck
to use an outdoor power source.
The switches for the interior
and exterior lighting
are underneath the
electrical box.
Workers install the light
fixtures, cabinetry, sink,
and serving window.
They also install the
gas lines that power the
commercial cooking equipment.
This truck has several
gas appliances--
a six burner gas
range with large oven,
a deep fryer, a charcoal grill,
and a flattop cooking surface.
The kitchen is equipped
with a ventilation
hood over the cooking area.
Its powerful fan gathers
smoke and sends it
out a vent on top of the truck.
It's time to outfit
the exterior.
Some food trucks are
painted, but most
use graphics that are digitally
printed on adhesive vinyl.
After positioning each
panel of the design,
they apply heat with a torch.
This removes trapped air,
stretching the vinyl over
rivets and other protrusions.
This mobile eatery
is ready to roll
with a kitchen that
meets fire code
and food service regulations.
It may not provide the ambiance
of a sit-down restaurant,
but when a food truck pulls up,
you never need a reservation.